بالطبع تهديد مباشر الجزائر حنا رافضين
رفض تم وقطعي بالنسبه للتدخل العسكري
الجيوش تحتشد في النيجر والجميع في حاله
التاهل بانتظار ساعه الصفر لتضرب عقاربها
الجزائر تقول كلمتها الاخيره بشان التدخل
العسكري في النيجر واجتماع جده للازمه
الاوكرانيه
والرئاسه الاوكرانيه بولندا اقرب صديق لنا
وهي اكبر منافسين فما هذا التناقض الجيش
الاوكراني يستبح الاجواء الروسيه مجددا
ليعلق العمل في المطارات وكياف تقصف
بالقنابل العنقوديه وروسيا ترد
يحاول انقاذ ما تبقى بعد غضب الغرب على
حكومته وفي البحر تشتد المعارك وممرات
روسيا الى القرم في خطر
وموسكو تبعثان برساله مرعبه من حدود
الولايات المتحده فكيف سترد واشنطن
النيجر تعلن ساعه الصفر
ساحه جديده للصراع العالمي في النيجر حيث
الهدوء الذي يسبق العاصفه الجارفه النيجر
التي اختارت طريقها بنفسها لكن الغرب
ينتهك السياده ويرفض طامعا في ثرواتها
سفن الغرب وبعد ان انتهت المهله التي
اعطتها مجموعه اوكواس الافريقيه للانقلاب
في النيجر اي دوله ذات الموقع الاستراتيجي
والتي تقع في قلب الساحل الافريقي كانت قد
حددت يوم السادس من اغسطس الجاري كاخر
موعد لتراجع الانقلاب واعاده بازار والا
فستتدخل عسكريا وبدعم من امريكا وفرنسا
وها نحن نكمل اليوم الاول بعد انتهاء
الموعد وما من جديد غير ان قاده الانقلاب
طلبوا من الحليف الروسي مساعده مجموعه
فاكنار الروسيه لمواجهه اي تدخل عسكري
محتمل في الوقت ذاته اعلن المج لس العسكري
للانقلاب استعداد قواته وجاهزيتها للتصدي
لاي عدوان خارجي ليصل المدد الروسي مع
مجموعه من مؤسسه فغنار العسكريه والتي حطت
رحالها في النيجر ليشتعل فتيل الحرب مجددا
بانتظار تدخل الايكواس وهنا يبدو ان
واشنطن سترد على تدخل فاجنر الروسيه هذه
المره واذا عرف السبب بطل العجب فالنيجر
تستضيف واحده من اكبر قواعد الطائرات
الامريكيه من دون طيار واكثرها تكلفه
والتي تقع بالتحديد في مدينه اغاديز وتعد
مركزا للمراقبه في منطقه غرب افريقيا مع
اكثر من الف جنديا امريكيا على الاراضي
النيجيريه وهو الحال ذاته بالنسبه لفرنسا
التي تضع ثقلها فنيجر باكثر من الف جنديا
ايضا فلماذا كل تلك الاعداد من الجنود
الاجابه بسيطه ففرنسا مثلا تخلت عن النفط
الروسي معتمده على المحطه النوويه والتي
سيغذيها اليورانيوم من نيجيري لكن موسكو
قد تقطع الطريق على باريس بعد ان ارسلت
فاجنر الى النيجر في المقابل ها هو الرئيس
الجزائري عبد المجيد تبون يلتحق بنظراته
رئيس بوركينا فاسو والرئيس المالي باعلانه
ان الجزائر ترفض قطعيا اي تدخل عسكري في
النيجر تبون اعلنها صراحه بان الجيش
الجزائري قوي
وسيواجه اي خطر يقترب من حدود بلده وبعدها
كله هل تتدخل مجموعه
من امريكي فرنسي وهناك سننتظر سيناريو
كارثي لاندلاع الحرب في البلاد التي تحظى
بدعم رسمي من بوتين شخصيا ومن جهه اخرى
القوات التي تدعمها امريكا وفرنسا فالى
اين المصير يا هؤلاء حرب الوسطات تشتعل
يتعدد الوسطاء والحرب واحده ففي الحرب
الاوكرانيه كل يدلو بدلوه وكل يجرب حظه في
الوساطه لعل وعسى وهنا يعلنها اندري
ايرماك مدير مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني قائلا
ان اجتماعات جدا في السعوديه قد شاركت
فيها اكثر من اربعين دوله وها هو يمثل
ثلاثه اضعاف مجره تمثيله في مشاورات
كوبنهاجن هذا يدل على اهتمام العالم غير
العادي لاقامه سلام مستدام وعهد على حد
تعبيره تتحدث عن الاهتمام فماذا عن
النتائج يا هذا لتجيب وكاله
الالمانيه نقلا عن دوائر الدبلوماسيه في
اجتماع جدا ان خطه السلام المحتمله اخرى
قد تم اقتراحها في المحادثات بالسعوديه
وهي خطه بديله ومختلفه عن خطه
واضافت انها قدمت من قبل السعوديه وعدد من
الدول الاخرى كما تم ابلاغ روسيا بها
ونقلت صحيفه
للسلام وان الدول الاخرى بدورها لم ترغب
اوكرانيا عن التخلي عن خطتها للسلام يبدو
ان الغرب ما عاد يحتمل دفع فاتوره الحرب
الاوكرانيه فبرايكم هل تنجح السعوديه
بالوساطه التي فشلت بها العديد من دول
العالم ليؤكد هنا نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسي ديماتري ماتفيد تعليقه على اجتماع
جده حول اوكرانيا ان اي مقترحات للسلام
لديها فرصه للنجاح اذا تم استيفاء ثلاث
شروط رئيسيه وهي مشاركه طرفي النزاع ووجوب
باخذ سياق التاريخي في الاعتبار حيث ان
دوله اوكرانيا لم تكن موجوده قبل عام
1991 فهي جزء من الامبراطوريه الروسيه
ووجوب اخذ الحقائق الحاليه في الاعتبار
وذلك وفق تعبير مدفداف الذي شدد على انه
لا حاجه للمفاوضات الان وعلى العدو ان
يجثوا على ركبته متوسلا الرحمه وبهذا الرب
نعود الى نقطه الصفر مجددا ويا فرحه ما
تمت لتاخذن بوصله الاحداث نحو الميدان في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه حيث تتواصل حرب
المسيرات التي غطت الاجواء في الاونه
الاخيره حيث اعلن حاكم منطقه بريانسك جنوب
غربي روسيا الكسندر بوجوماس ان الدفاعات
الجويه اسقطت مسيرتين اوكرانيتين
في المقاطعه بينما اعلنت الدفاع الروسي ان
دفاعاتها الجويه اسقطت مسيره اوكرانيه قرب
مدينه في ضواحي موسكو دون وقوع اضرار او
اصابات وفي وقت سابق اعلن عمده العاصمه
الروسيه
ان الدفاعات الجويه اسقطت الطائره مسيره
استهدفت العاصمه موسكو
وهناكوفو جنوب غربي موسكو قيودا جزئيه
مؤقته على حركه اقلاع وهبوط الطائرات
ليقول امين مجلس الامن القومي الاوكراني
اوليكسي دانيلا ان طائره مسيره الاوكرانيه
مع كل مهمه القتاليه جديده تصبح اكثر دقه
والمشغلين اكثر خبره فهل هي كذلك برايكم
من جهتها نشرت وزاره الطوارئ الروسيه مقطع
فيديو يظهر محاوله رجال الاطفاء اخماد
الحريق الذي حدث بسبب قصف اوكراني
بالذخائر العنقوديه واشعل النيران بجامعه
هجمات الاوكراني لا تتوقف فقد اعلن حاكم
شبه جزيره القرم
تضرر تشونها المؤدي الى شبه الجزيره اثر
هجوم صاروخي اوكراني وهذا الجسر هو واحد
من بين عدد قليل من الروابط بين شبه
الجزيره القرم والبر الرئيسيه لاوكرانيا
بينما كانت وكاله الملاحه الاوكرانيه قد
حذرت من ان سته مواد اروسيه على البحر
الاسود تقع في منطقه خطر الحرب والمعارك
تشتد يا ساده الرد الروسي لم يتاخر حيث
افادت قنوات المراقبه الاوكرانيه ان ما لا
يقل عن سبع قاذفات استراتيجيه الروسيه من
طرازتو 95 ام اس محمله بالصواريخ وتحلق في
الاجواء اما على الصعيد السياسي فيحاول
الرئيس الاوكراني انقاذ ما تبقى من غضب
الغرب من فساد حكومته حيث اعلن زيلينسكي
عن موجه جديده من الاقالات في اطار مكافحه
الفساد الذي يعصف با وكرانيا في ظل حكمه
ولا في تطويكالاتورز الى ان زيلينس كيمن
خلال تصريحاته يحاول اقناع الشركاء
الغربيين ان كياف تحاول انهاء تاريخ متجذر
من الكسب الغير المشروع وفي سياق السياسه
ايضا صرح مستشار مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني
ميخائيل بودالياك بان اقرب شريك واقرب
اليوم هي بولندا ومن حيث المبدا سيستمر
الامر حتى نهايه الحرب وفق تعبيره مضيفا
وعند انتهاء الازمه بالطبع ستكون لدينا
علاقات تنافسيه وسنتنافس على اسواق معينه
والاسواق الاستهلاكيه وما الى ذلك عن اي
تنافس يتحدث وبعيدا عن الحرب الاوكرانيه
نفذت قوه البحريه من روسيا والصين دوريه
مشتركه بالقرب من صاحب الاسكا في وقت سابق
من الاسبوع الماضي ماذا فعل الولايات
المتحده الى استنفار اربع مدمرات وطائره
استطلاع لمراقبه تحركات الدوريه حسب ما
افادت صحيفه
عن مسؤولين امريكيين قولهم ان 11 سفينه
روسيه والصينيه اقتربت من جزر الوشيان
بولايه الاسكا الامريكيه وهو الاسطول
الاكبر من نوعه الذي يقترب من الاراضي
الامريكيه
[موسيقى]